you're here I've heard of this brand is
influenced by know a lot to say that
this burger is influenced finding out
and you can look at the burgers and
fries and other values it's very almost
identical
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh and old cheese done in a no beginner
algebra the EO tanara
the way the cheese melted into like the
patties yeah very similar almost the
same
[Music]
it could easily God be mean much now
Cheetara
I keep a little bit of Brittany offering
a little bit I think the 5 percent 5
percent 5 percent of welfare and then
the Koresh fizzle
I like their packaging it's brown it's
like kind of a little from the risers
you know not price not even not even
close but that's great yeah right there
[Music]
me
for sure
this is not
it's really good it's pretty good
you work
laughs
as in and out here I'm just not a worker
person who do I like it really like I
Drive this it would be really hard to
tell hey unsolved is on a new channel
and now you're part subscribe here that
was my part